out of the 270 doctors in regards to joe
rogan trying to censor him only 100 were
actually doctors which is quite
interesting so let me
what page is that on by the way is that
a page five deal let me go to page five
uh following the release of a viral uh
joe rogan experience podcast episode
featuring guest dr robert malone a
letter from uh more than 270 doctors
describing rogan as a
by the way this is a post-millennial
story describing rogan as a menace to
public health was sent to spotify during
urgent accompany censor the podcast are
it's uh since been revealed though that
a large portion of those doctors are not
partisan practice and medical doctors
over 50 were phd academics 60 were
college professors 29 were nurses 10
were students former medical residents
and a handful of science podcasters were
included in the signatures
uh signatories of the letter dr malone's
interview has reached many tens of
millions of listeners vulnerable to
predatory medical misinformation mass
information mass misinformation events
of this scale have extraordinary
dangerous ramifications the letter
states uh what what difference does it
make if all of them were doctors what if
all of them were doctors like doctors
can't disagree with each other i mean
you know you're gonna get 270 doctors
that say this and you can find 270 that
say something different and that's
debate right that's heresy there is but
one science and it is the word of
science how dare you blaspheme science
who which doctors get to speak for
science who who who decides which
doctors get to speak for science anthony
fauci he is the science he is science
right i am the science
praised science praise be to this i
agree with you i don't think even if it
was
270 doctors 2700 doctors that spotify
would have changed their stance
whatsoever we talked about this last
podcast they've they're winning right
now yeah and if they even if they were
even a little bit you know concerned
with these 270 doctors the fact that
it's just actually laughable it's like
well it's actually a nurse and actually
a an emt and a couple drunk guys are
actually uh internet like i don't want a
guy who stayed at a holiday and
experienced exactly i think it's only
going to strengthen their stance i don't
think spotify is going to do anything if
there's anybody that's uncancible at
this point yeah we're looking at them
right here
look this is the same thing to happen
with chappelle you try to suppress
speech like this and you draw more
attention to it it's the strength effect
the streisand effect
i tweeted about this yes the barber you
know what that is the barber strategy
let's hear about it she she was trying
to like suppress aerial footage of her
home by like suing the photographer that
took the pictures and the lawsuit
attracted attention to the pictures and
then millions of people saw them so she
drew attention to these pictures that
she didn't want anybody to see that's
the streisand effect it happens every
time they try to censor people like this
i tweeted about this when i saw that
happen i'm like now i have to watch this
interview now i have to i want to see
what they don't want me to see
but by the way just swoop for thought
here one of the most important men in
the world today i want to keep
emphasizing how important this man is
and protect this man folks i'm telling
you right now there's a guy named daniel
ack he is the ceo of a company called
spotify if it wasn't for him joe rogan
would be off of spotify power to daniel
act the ceo again highly paid ceo folks
we should be like really he makes a lot
of money evil yeah the highly paid ceo
has the backbone calling on him to
apologize right now for how much money
he is he needs to apologize how dare you
sir he makes 17 billion more than the
average spotify artist oh my gosh listen
danny like you're stuck keep doing what
you're doing you're impacting the world
in a positive way for giving a voice
what i don't like though pat is the what
robert malone told you in that in that
interview that doesn't exist
the the name that shall not be named
they they
they went and and the biden
administration said don't say this he
says something and instead of them
counteracting it
there's a hit piece the next day in the
atlantic
and then social media linkedin and
twitter used that hit piece
as an excuse
to take him down as fake news right so
there's very very clear
causality causation the whole now
whatever but there's there's a very
clear chain of events here and it's like
man they've got a whole hit squad
infrastructure on how to justify taking
you down there's there's a literal plan
in place a censorship plan in place
that's coming from the people that we
have in charge of protecting there's
also markets devastating you've got uh
rumble hosted his interview after
youtube took it down right didn't they
they actually took that down i think
i think that's something yeah rumble is
hosted rumble's like an alternative to
youtube that's like a free speech
alternative and they're like they're the
views on that are going crazy and people
are flocking to rumble um so there's a
market response to this too where people
are you know getting fed up with youtube
and everybody telling them what they can
and can't see like let us decide for
ourselves let us take in information
from both sides and decide for ourselves
like trust us to do that i got a call
with the rumble ceo this week they
reached out
listen all i trust
i'm telling you folks no matter how much
go through
idolizing competitors to demonizing
competitors to humanizing competitors
trust competition it's good for you i'm
telling you competition is good for all
of us so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]